in this video we're going to talk about
economic growth and i want to be very
careful here because depending on the
context people including economists
might mean different things by economic
growth in everyday language when people
are talking about economic growth
they're usually just talking about an
expansion in the output of an economy
over time so if real gdp is increasing
they might consider that to be economic
growth but the context that we're going
to talk about in this video and this is
one that you might see in an
introductory economics class or an ap
economics class we aren't just talking
about an increase in real gdp over time
we are talking about an increase in the
full employment output over time
regardless of where we are in the
economic cycle so keep that in mind as
you watch this video
if we're just talking about the increase
of real gdp we're going to call that an
expansion
not necessarily economic growth
and we're going to call real gdp
decreasing as being equal to a
contraction
when we talk about economic growth we're
actually talking about the full
employment output increasing
and this could happen somewhat
independently of where we are in the
actual economic cycle let's do a little
diagram to make that a little bit
clearer
so right over here i have plotted real
gdp of an economy versus time
and what you see here in yellow is how
the real gdp is fluctuating and it's
fluctuating around its full employment
output
let's pick this time right over here
call it t sub 1.
so right at this point
that is our full employment output let's
call it y sub f sub 1. but we see that
our economy is performing above our full
employment output we have a positive
output gap
if we go from that point in time fast
forward a little bit to t2 so let's go
to t sub 2 here because the
y sub f right over here the full
employment output right here is flat
according to this we would not have
experienced any economic growth from t
sub 1 to t sub 2 even though the real
gdp would have grown we would have grown
from this point to this point right over
here so one way to think about it is we
are expanding as long as this curve is
upward sloping but if the full
employment output is not changing we are
not experiencing economic growth
the times where we actually are
experiencing economic growth are times
where our full employment output is
changing so let's say from this time
right over there to this time right over
there and notice that is happening
theoretically during a contraction this
is a contraction right over here where
real gdp is actually pulling back but if
we knew truly what the full employment
output were and were able to plot it
like this theoretically we actually are
experiencing economic growth here
despite a contraction
to appreciate this let's look at other
models that we have studied in economics
so we think about a production
possibilities curve the ones that we
typically see only have two goods or
services a real economy is going to be
much more complex it would have millions
of goods and services but it's very hard
to draw a million dimension production
possibilities curve but what this shows
us is at a snapshot in time what is the
full employment output and it shows us
the trade-off between these two goods or
services
now if we're in a situation where we're
behind the production possibilities
curve that is a negative output gap and
it's possible that over time we go from
this negative output gap back to the
production possibilities curve that
would be an expansion in the economy but
by the definition that we're talking
about here which is not what is
typically talked about in the news or
something like this we would not call
that economic growth economic growth
happens when we push out the production
possibilities curve when we have an
increase in our full employment output
so economic growth is maybe through some
new technology or some more workers or
resources or just better institutions
we're able to push our production
possibilities curve out
this is an example of economic
economic
growth
so for example this could be our
production possibilities curve at let's
say
t3 where this is t sub 3 right over here
and then this is our production
possibilities curve at t sub 4 where
this is t sub 4 right over here where
our full employment output has increased
we can also think about the same idea
using our aggregate demand or aggregate
supply model
when we study that we saw that in the
short run because of say a demand shock
or a supply shock we could be operating
to the left or the right of our full
employment output creating these
positive or negative output gaps but
over time we're going to gravitate back
to this full employment output and so as
long as our production possibilities
curve isn't getting pushed out isn't
changing or as long as our long-run
aggregate supply curve is not changing
according to the definition that i'm
talking about in this video we are not
seeing economic growth the analog for
what we saw in this ppc curve is maybe
this is the long run aggregate supply
curve at t3
but if our economy has more resources
maybe more population more more natural
resources better technology better
institutions maybe it's able to produce
more at full employment and in that
situation our long run aggregate supply
curve would shift to the right
and so this could be our long run
aggregate supply curve at time
t4
so this is full employment output let's
call that sub 3 this would be full
employment output sub 4. the big
takeaway here is regardless of where we
are in the expansion or contraction of
our business cycles
the economic growth is the change in
that blue line and if we're looking at
the ppc it's a shift out of our ppc of
our production possibilities curve if
we're looking at the aggregate demand
aggregate supply model it is a shift to
the right of our long run aggregate
supply curve
and once again what are the things that
can cause that and these are good to
know
a notion of capital traditionally people
have just thought hey more factories
more resources more land maybe that will
push things out and it definitely could
but more modern definitions are thinking
human capital hey if we have a better
educated workforce a more skilled
workforce that can also matter
people also think about things like
technology if we can discover better
ways of putting together the resources
we have that can also increase our
productivity and that's what we would
call technology in an economics context
and things like institutions matter as
well
you could imagine if your bureaucracy is
really slows things down if it takes
forever to get a permit to do something
well that might put a hamper on what the
full employment output is but if the
institutions become much more efficient
well then that might allow the country
allow that economy to produce more at
full employment so all of these things
could push out your ppc could push your
long run aggregate supply curve to the
right or cause this blue curve which
represents your full employment output
to move up over time all of that would
be economic growth